hey everyone it's sarah thredson err
sorry and calm and today i'm going to
demonstrate how to find the carotid
pulse point and whenever you're
assessing the pulse you will be looking
at a few things one thing will be the
rate how fast is it along with the
strength and you'll be grading it on a
scale zero to three with zero being
absent one plus it's week two plus it's
normal and three plus it's bounding and
then you'll want to look at the rhythm
is it regular or irregular and this
artery is most commonly assessed during
CPR in an adult and it supplies our
brain and our head with blood now
whenever you are assessing the carotid
artery you will assess each side at a
time you will not do it bilaterally
because we don't want to stimulate the
vagus nerve which can drop the heart
rate and decrease circulation to the
brain to find this pulse point we'll use
the landmarks of the jaw because we're
going to go below the jaw we're gonna
have the patient tilt the head like this
and we're gonna find the trachea and the
sternocleidomastoid on't forget to check
out our other videos on how to check the
other pulse points on the body thank you
so much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos